questo titolo che ho scelto per il mio
intervento
aiutiamoli a fare da soli oltre a essere
forse una citazione che più si addice a
dei bambini che ha dei dati ha però un
po di senso per me l'apertura dei dati
pubblici nel senso di prodotti dalle
pubbliche amministrazioni o anche
prodotti da comunità online da aziende
che oggi cominciano a vedere il valore
di questa messa in condivisione deriva
anche dal fatto che il dato messo a
disposizione di qualcun altro
aperto al riuso abilità tutta la
creatività che oggi c'è stata presentata
parlando di riutilizzo degli spazi di
riutilizzo degli oggetti
i dati a loro volta possono essere
riutilizzati in modi assolutamente
inattesi una delle loro caratteristiche
peraltro interessanti è che si
riutilizzano all'infinito senza generare
troppo inquinamento un pochettino di
entropia la generano pure loro a seconda
dei server su cui stanno però se non
altro non non si consumano e anzi spesso
nel momento in cui vengono riutilizzati
assumono nuovo valore perché magari sono
collegati ad altri dati perché degli
errori sono corretti perché il
riutilizzo appunto genera nuovo valore
sui dati e questo peraltro lo vediamo
anche nei casi di aziende pensiamo a
google tanto per dirne una che sulla
base della raccolta di dati sul web e
sulla valle dei click di chi usa questi
dati da un ulteriore senso alla loro
mappa dei siti web cioè il fatto che io
usi una piattaforma spesso genera nuovi
dati sui dati della piattaforma e questo
aumenta il valore della piattaforma
stessa è open data dati aperti diciamo
io in particolare vi parlerò di dati
pubblici e o di dati di community aperti
di cosa stiamo parlando cosa cosa sono
empiricamente cosa che si può immaginare
partiamo dal presupposto che le
pubbliche amministrazioni praticamente
dall'inizio della storia hanno
cominciato a raccogliere dati per fini
più o meno nobili cioè i templi antichi
dai sumeri a agli egizi tutti quelli che
ha raccolto decimi nella storia
chi produceva quale quanta di dicano le
pubbliche amministrazioni hanno questa
abitudine di prendere nota di un sacco
di informazioni spesso per un fine
abbastanza specifico ma poi il
riutilizzo può essere per fini diversi
primo fine come avete intuito della far
pagare tasse continua a essere un fine
abbastanza importante però per esempio
dati raccolti di di nuovo per far pagare
tasse in questo esempio qua a prezzi
delle case tanto per dirne uno
torna al 2004 se non era questo e uno
dei primi mashup di cui io abbia
conoscenza nel regno unito un no profit
si era messa a riunire dati diversi dati
sul mercato immobiliare appunto dati sui
trasporti pubblici a mappe generate
dagli utenti come quelle di open street
map che a loro volta però vengono dall
apertura di dati pubblici dvd bd foto
aeree o addirittura satellitari spesso
messa a disposizione da è da enti
pubblici e anche altri dati per fare un
servizio abbastanza semplice e molto
utile per i cittadini cioè capire dato
un budget dato un luogo di lavoro data
una disponibilità alzarsi a una certa
ora al mattino per essere in ufficio che
ne so alle otto e mezza dove possa
andare a cercare casa ecco le
informazioni su quanto costano le case
su quanto tempo ci mettono i mezzi
pubblici per arrivare in un certo posto
le informazioni sulle sulle sue mappe
gli orari eccetera sono tutte
informazioni che esistono in qualche
database naturalmente sparse spesso non
accessibili mettendole insieme si può
fare un servizio nuovo che non era
quello per cui i dati sono stati
raccolti per o riutilizzati con un po di
fantasia i dati mi permettono di capire
perché più dov'è che io ho più
probabilità di trovare una casa che mi
posso permettere e fa al caso mio
questo non solo nel regno unito in un
progetto innovativo nel 2011 se non mi
sbaglio a torino hanno fatto un giochino
simile che è stato anche premiato al
piemonte e visual contest e qui mettendo
un po di parametri su quanto mi
interessa avere certe caratteristiche
per kasami e quando sono disposto a
pagare ecco io per esempio ho compilato
questo questa piccola web app e come
vedete sparita tutto a torino perché non
potevo permettermi di pagava tanto la
casa e avevo pure delle pretese di avere
servizi verde e altri cosa ecco però a
torino sud effettivamente ci sono dei
punti in cui
potevo cercarmi casa in realtà la casa
avevo trovata prima di usare questa
applicazione ma è uno dei pallini che
rimangono accessibili sul sulla mappa
quindi usi che possono anche essere
pubblici qui diciamo l'utilità per i
cittadini abbastanza evidente ma anche
servizi come il traduttore di google
sono in parte addestrati e su dati
pubblici e usi pubblici ma non
necessariamente fatti dal pubblico
abilitati spesso dai dati pubblici ma
servizi fatti da privati quindi la
parola chiave è anche qui riutilizzo
riuso dico riutilizzo anziché riuso
perché nella nostra normativa ormai
questo concetto è stato in qualche modo
ufficializzato e la keyword a cercare
nelle nelle leggi europee italiane e
riutilizzo in inglese dicono riuso e
quindi fate voi però è veramente una
parola chiave un utilizzo diverso da
quello per cui il dato era stato
originariamente raccolto peraltro un
riutilizzo che può anche essere per fini
commerciali per trarne un profitto
purché il soggetto che lo che riutilizza
questi dati
diciamo non lo faccia cercando di
snaturare per esempio la percezione di
questi dati nei consumatori del dato
stesso per esempio se io riutilizzo
un dato pubblico non dovrei cercare di
far apparire a un'informazione ufficiale
originaria di diversa da quella che era
però al di là di queste cautele il
riutilizzo nel 70 da parte della
comunità europea è stato pensato come
uno l'utilizzo che abilità sia usi a
favore di altri cittadini magari fatti
da soggetti no profit sia un riutilizzo
eventualmente anche profit quindi detto
che cosa sono sinteticamente questi dati
aperti perché è interessante parlarne
perché come parlava come si diceva prima
parlando di riutilizzo di oggetti e
materiali il valore di questi dati se
diciamo posti al nuovo uso può essere
particolarmente significativo ora io non
so francamente quanto ci si possa fidare
di stime che dicono quanto valgono i
dati pubblici resi più utilizzabili in
un intero paese sono sempre molto
difficili però parliamo sicuramente di
centinaia di milioni di euro e di contro
il costo di mettere questi dati a
disposizione
guardando ai progetti più ambiziosi il
portale open data della commissione
europea e diciamo diversi ordini di
grandezza sotto cioè un qualche decina o
centinaia di migliaia di euro sono fatti
progetti molto ambiziosi di messa a
disposizione di dati da cui ci
ritroviamo effettivamente ad avere
un'opportunità un'opportunità che
effettivamente sarebbe poco responsabile
non cogliere e anche perché diciamo le
ricette per rendere questi dati utili
per altri scopi
effettivamente ormai cominciamo a
conoscere abbastanza bene da un lato
chiaramente abbiamo bisogno della
materia prima dei dati
parla oggi in particolare dei dati
aperti del settore pubblico dei governi
delle amministrazioni perché sono i
soggetti che diciamo per design
dovrebbero agire non solo nel proprio
interesse ma nell'interesse collettivo e
che anche lì per design e raccolgono
molti dati perché il processo
amministrativo è bene o male strutturato
e quindi se un'associazione può dirmi io
su alcune cose vado un po abbraccio non
ho traccia informatizzata strutturata di
quello che sto facendo difficilmente la
pubblica amministrazione mi dirà questo
infatti male finché si vuole ma i dati
di solito ci sono e aprirli peraltro è
un'occasione per comprenderli meglio per
analizzarli
e dare loro un senso che sia
comprensibile anche ad altri e non solo
chi sta dentro all'amministrazione un
esempio diciamo famoso dentro la piccola
comunità degli open data perché l'amico
maurizio napolitano ne parla spesso in
giro è un dataset pubblico in cui c'era
una colonna gianfranco chi è gianfranco
si chiedevano molti è una colonna di 0 e
1 con scritto gianfranco forse
gianfranco era un signore che valida va
che la cui quella riga fosse corretta
cioè il check di qualità di
appropriatezza per un certo fine era
quella riga poteva essere usata o era
stata ma aveva il bollino di gianfranco
ecco una tabella che viene pubblicata
per l'esterno sia una colonna gianfranco
ha bisogno di un metadato di una
spiegazione e dare queste spiegazioni
all'esterno a volte fa sì che anche i
colleghi di gianfranco che non lo
conoscono troppo bene possono capire
meglio quel dato anche senza andare a
chiedere a gianfranco dopo che
gianfranco è andato in pensione per cui
ecco quel questo punto chi è chi è
gianfranco e diciamo un piccolo aneddoto
che però dà l'idea del valore di fare
open data prima di tutto per chi apre i
dati per le amministrazioni stesse
perché se qualcun altro devo cominciare
a capirli bene io a spiegarlo in maniera
tale che anche altri possano
riutilizzarli gli altri che li
utilizzano possono essere un po chi ne
ha voglia
però sicuramente nell'esperienza diciamo
gli ultimi otto anni di cui mi sono
occupato di queste cose sono spesso o
diciamo degli attivisti degli hacker
civici dei soggetti che hanno un po di
competenze sui dati non necessariamente
dei laureati in ingegneria informatica
ma della gente che smanetta con i dati
che sa arrangiarsi per diciamo fare dei
le piccole app che utilizzano i dati
oppure in alcuni casi delle aziende che
spesso raccontano un po meno rispetto
agli hacker civici quello che fanno però
che cominciano a essere degli
utilizzatori comunque importanti di dati
pubblici quindi dati pubblici sono
l'ingrediente base quindi la materia
prima cosa serve per mettere a
disposizione questa materia prima
ho citato queste quattro posti quattro
punti diciamo abilitatori 76 secondo
miller che è stato uno dei pionieri
degli open data in nuova zelanda dove
hanno fatto dei progetti molto
interessanti servono almeno tre di
queste quattro cose cioè può essere
utile avere una leadership magari una
leadership politica qualcuno che ti dice
come ha fatto obama negli stati uniti
ogni ufficio pubblico e joy tot mesi
pubblica almeno tre dataset non importa
cosa sono ha cominciato a pormi il
problema quindi una forte leadership
qualcuno che ci mette la faccia polipo
politicamente può essere un eroe che non
a quella leadership ma è uno che si
sbatte dentro la pubblica
amministrazione uno che lo fa succede ai
lo stesso non dico dal basso non so che
non è fuori dall'amministrazione ed è
dentro magari non è proprio il suo
compito ma fa tutto il possibile perché
succede magari risponde alle mail degli
utilizzatori di notte va sulle mailing
list a spiegare che i dati nuovi ci sono
e si possono utilizzare poi naturalmente
può essere un elemento interessante
anche una crisi d'altra parte per
rendersi conto che è importante
riutilizzare gli oggetti materiali gli
edifici
abbiamo un po bisogno del problema
dell'inquinamento del problema
dell'edificio che crolla e che ci fa
stringere il cuore che di vedere un
problema per trovare delle soluzioni
nuove ecco penso che questo elemento di
solito sia abbondantemente a
disposizione uno su tre la crisi ci
arriva diciamo facilmente è un altro
diciamo degli elementi che possono
ovviamente aiutare è una pressione
esterno magari da parte dei cittadini
quindi chi come voi si interessa a temi
che hanno un impatto sociale è
sicuramente uno degli ingredienti che
possono abilitare l'apertura dei dati
pubblici per esempio trovando almeno
un alleato dentro a pubblicazione che
sia a livello politico e di leadership
che sia a livello di un funzionario che
per qualche dato ha voglia di farlo
finire in qualche posto in cui può
essere riutilizzato che ne sto pensando
al riutilizzo potrebbe essere
interessante che ha beccato a capire
quali sono tutti i punti in una città in
cui conferire alcuni rifiuti
particolarmente dannosi l'olio esausto
di cui si è parlato è un elemento
particolarmente difficile da trattare
perché io l'unico posto nella vita in
cui ho trovato delle giare per il
conferimento dell'olio esausto è un
campeggio in toscana dove evidentemente
la sensibilità per il tema è forte e se
non lo conferisce di finisce in mare a
dio di fronte al campeggio e sicuramente
non crea un vantaggio per il turismo
locale
però ecco a casa mia a torino dove
diavolo post io portare dell'olio
esausto è un elemento più complesso e
questo aumenta il costo per chi voglia
anche avere un comportamento
relativamente virtuoso almeno non
disastroso di mettere in pratica le sue
buone intenzioni
quindi il riutilizzo questo riutilizzo
abilitato dalla messa a disposizione dei
dati
poi mette diciamo a disposizione del
mondo delle cose che possono essere
usate in maniera assolutamente
inaspettate un esempio così carino che
passa per 2 step degli utilizzi può
essere questa su questa borsa c'è una
cartina geografica
questa cartina geografica viene da open
street panchina un progetto di community
dove spesso si riutilizzano dati
pubblici di tipo cartografico che a loro
volta vengono mai magari dalla foto
aeree da cada campagna di raccolta di
questo tipo
e poi aggiungendo diciamo dell'hacking
sui modi di rappresentare il dato sui
pattini da dare alla mappa alcuni hanno
realizzato delle cartine in
un'interazione molto siamo artistica
quale latta e così via
e un ulteriore riutilizza tricea pensato
di costruire un business sul fare degli
oggetti di design sito si chiama dress
map che hanno come elemento questa
questo questa mappa l geografica simile
intuizione è stata usata per fare della
carta da pacco che ogni negoziante si
può customizzare così da un lato c'è
magari il puntino del negozio sulla
mappa dall'alto e diciamo una
caratteristica un po esclusiva un po
particolare di un pacco regalo magari
comprato nell'area storica di una città
personalmente quello che sto facendo
diciamo da un paio d'anni insieme a
degli amici e soci è un riutilizzo anche
di tipo commerciale per esempio questo
portale contratti pubblici punto org che
è già accessibile in una versione
veramente alfa diciamo per chiunque è un
progetto di riutilizzo di molti dati
pubblicati per fini di trasparenza sui
contratti della pubblica amministrazione
quindi un supporto a chi voglia
monitorare i contratti pubblici ma è
anche una attività di business in cui
noi questi dati li stiamo diciamo
vendendo in quanto tali o nei progetti
che li integrano con altri dati a dei
soggetti for profit che sono interessati
da tifoni impresa i dati sulla pubblica
amministrazione
e così via quindi di nuovo un dato
pubblico un utilizzo che in meno in
parte è pubblico e penso a impatto
sociale positivo ma sostenuto per lo più
con soldi privati di soggetti
interessati
diciamo a unire i loro dati a questi
quindi diciamo data un'idea di queste
che sono alcune possibili ricette di
riutilizzo volevo menzionarli
rapidamente due risorse che oggi si
hanno a disposizione per chi di voi
avesse un'idea in cui per esempio i dati
pubblici possono diventare un asset fare
qualcosa uno è la normativa sulla
cosiddetta freedom of information c'è
oggi è diventato molto più facile in
italia a chiedere di poter accedere a
dei dati pubblici e ottenerlo facilmente
l'altro è un'infrastruttura wiki data la
versione diciamo database di wikipedia
sta diventando veramente un po il punto
di raccordo tra moltissimi dei dati
pubblici governativi o di community che
ci sono online quindi se avete dei dati
che possono essere utili volete
condividerli questo vale anche per
alcuni dei progetti di cui si è parlato
oggi e questo può essere un posto
interessante insieme a open street map
che ho già citato quindi ciò detto
vorrei chiamare in causa voi vorrei
chiedervi davvero cosa vi sta a cuore e
se ci sono dei modi perché i dati lo
rendano un qualcosa di più utile di più
potente per generare un impatto sociale
grazie
[Applauso]